hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV i'm here
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas with Cato
Institute executive vice president David
bows David thanks for joining us we're
here at the Freedom Fest talking about
whether we're at the you know we're
seeing a Rome part to whether it's the
decline of the United States yet a lot
of people that I've talked to around
have been speaking about 2013 being more
of a kind of extended libertarian
Christmas ever since the rand paul
filibuster and a series of government
scandal has been sort of pushing more
people into a libertarian direction we
finally living in the libertarian
moments dead boss well in a way we are
the problem is libertarian moments
always come after the government sees is
a huge new chunk of power so you know we
have the bailouts and the tarp and the
stimulus bill and suddenly there's a
mass Tea Party movement unfortunately we
already got the bailouts in the tarp and
the stimulus we had the same thing in
1994 and now we're we're having the
reaction to the sensor of the stalking
of journalists and the surveillance of
all the rest of us and the IRS scandal
but unfortunately it's because we found
out there doing all these things so it's
not like we've actually stopped very
many of them we've just created a
libertarian moment where boy are we
ticked off right you know that you
mentioned the tea party thing right so
that's kind of a 2010 at least that's
how it expressed politically in a in an
election how would you rate the
performance of let said it's 2010 class
did did something sustained did we do it
are we living with something new that
didn't exactly exist before under the
name Liberty movement I mean are you are
you optimistic yeah I think there is
more of a Liberty movement Ron Paul's
campaigns Gary Johnson's campaign the
Tea Party the marijuana liberalisation
and the marriage equality movements
those groups don't all agree with each
other but they pretty much all agree
with libertarians so yes I think all of
that is good and there is something more
that you can call a Liberty movement
than you used to be able to is it
sustainable well that's always a
challenge
people get angry and they go marching
the streets and then they go home and
keeping that anger and that energy going
is difficult and it's also difficult
when you elect people to Congress to
keep them on your team and that's a
little difficult to judge because you've
got a Republican House that can pass
anything it wants to but in going
anywhere else and so the result has sort
of been gridlock which is better than
Congress passing laws seeing some
criticism of libertarianism this year
surprise surprise and one of them has
been that there's no real governing
program with it as much people saying no
do you think that there's enough sort of
members of a Liberty movement where it's
actually time to start talking about
what would libertarian ish people do
when they govern is there more like a
concrete policy discussion I have the
complete plan the book it's called
potato handbook for policymakers it's 67
chapters you want to know what
libertarians if they control both houses
of Congress would do about taxes
entitlements the war in Iraq we have it
all in the Cato handbook for
policymakers now it doesn't mean that
there is any libertarian group of
members of Congress ready to do that
right but in that sense there is a plan
I am all in favor of saying no no is a
good thing to say when you're a member
of Congress and politicians saying yes
to war and taxes and spending and
regulation is what got us into all this
mess so I'm all in favor of saying no
but if you want specific plans for how
to walk our way back out of the Social
Security mess how to walk our way out of
Iraq and Afghanistan we have them this
huge disconnect right now between kind
of bipartisan foreign policy consensus
Washington to the extent that that
consensus exists and American public
opinion when it comes to the waging of
foreign policy when it comes to you know
should we be funding people in Syria how
should we be dealing with Egypt where do
you see public opinion trending on
foreign policy issue and are we getting
to a place where it's easier to bridge
that gap but we finally seeing some
practical impact of a less robust
interventionism
going forward well you would hope so
it's absolutely true that there's been a
trend toward opposition to foreign
adventurism and yet in Washington even
in Washington it's constrained you don't
see anybody saying let's invade Libya
and Syria they're saying let's use
drones let's create no-fly zones let's
give arms to the rebels dangerous things
that led us into Vietnam that can lead
you into Wars but they know the American
people would not tolerate let's just go
in and fight a war in Syria so I think
public opinion is putting a constraint
on what they're able to do but it is
absolutely true that among the political
class the neo-cons and the liberal
internationalists the liberal Hawks
together they want to be active what's
the point of having this great military
and being in government unless you're
going around doing things both
domestically and internationally so the
fact that the American people would just
like to leave the rest of the world
alone it's tough to organize that
sentiment and then you have the partisan
problem where's the anti-war movement
since barack obama became president
right how much about these kind of
things foreign policy is a great example
of it because we've we have the phrase
military-industrial complex so we
understand how there can be structural
kind of interests that perpetuate this
how much in that but also in other areas
of government do you attribute the
continued growth of all of this stuff at
you know despite public opinion how much
of it is like the structural complex
that exists that perpetuates and how
much is sort of public opinion that
adheres you know to these tribalistic
political parties that that will
therefore back Barack Obama during the
same policies to SiC Cheney how do you
how do you kind of judge that after well
they're right there are a variety of
things there certainly is the problem
that when you promised people money and
then you start giving it to them it's
very difficult to organize them to want
to stop getting the money so there's
public support for things that help me
there's also the public choice problem
that the organized interest have more
influence in Washington than the
unorganized interest so all the people
out there who are paying a dollar or
five dollars for each government program
very hard to get them excited about any
one of them whereas the people who are
getting the fifty thousand or a hundred
thousand dollars for the farm program or
the tariffs or the wall street bailout
those people are organized and they're
always working the halls of Washington
and the policy the bureaucrats
themselves are working the halls of
Washington so the bureaucrats are a
permanent lobby for more government and
trying to organize a tea party or an
anti-war movement or anything else
against that kind of permanent
government is very difficult and money
permeates every part of the government
when Jim Gray said he was going to run
for Congress on an anti drug war
platform he said to Republican
congressman from California told him I
wish you well be great to have a
congressman up here who took on the drug
war but you're going to find that
there's drug war money in every nook and
cranny of the federal government the
Education Department the Interior
Department the State Department and that
means that every one of those
departments and sub departments is up on
Capitol Hill lobbying against any change
in the drug war and that's also true for
all the other things the government gets
into the money just kind of weaves
itself in and out of all these different
agencies very hard to break all that
unless you just have a general collapse
final question you're from Kentucky am i
right Senator Rand Paul's home state
you've been in libertarianism for a long
time Rand Paul this week got into some
publicity hot water when an old aided
co-authored one of his books Jack hunter
came out that his southern Avenger days
included Confederate luchador masks and
and cheering John Wilkes Booth every at
every Lincoln assassination anniversary
why does this keep happening to
libertarianism well I don't know that
does keep happening to libertarianism it
does seem to keep happening to the Paul
family and so what exactly the
connection is there I'm not sure there
are people who call themselves
libertarians
who somehow think Austrian economics and
the Southern Confederacy have something
in common I don't know what it is the
idea that there are people who can get
upset about the feds expansion of its
power and are blithely unconcerned about
defending a government that was holding
four million people in Chains up until
the Civil War I don't understand that
kind of libertarianism now in Jack
hunters particular case I've seen some
writings that he did earlier this year
where he seemed genuinely contrite about
being a young jerk so I don't so I don't
want to judge him personally it does
seem like we when we hire somebody at
Cato we run a google search you would
think if you were a u.s. senator and you
ran a google search you might have
wondered whether it was a good idea to
hire somebody who says that every year
he toasts the assassination of the
president from Kentucky well on that
cheery note thank you David bows for
joining us here for a reason TV I'm Matt
Welch